ich habe sechs personen die möglichkeit
gegeben 500 euro zu gewinnen wie das
ganze ausgegangen ist erfahrt ihr in
dieser ersten folge contest das
spielprinzip funktioniert folgendermaßen
es wird zwei teams geben und beide teams
bekommen eine rote und eine blaue karte
wenn sich beide teams für die blaue
karte entscheiden teilen sie sich 300
euro wenn sich das eine team für die
blaue und das andere für die rote karte
entscheidet erhält das team mit der
roten karte die gesamten 500 euro wenn
es aber dazu kommen sollte dass beide
teams die rote karte nehmen bekommt
niemand etwas
die hand zu nehmen wenn ihr team kennt
[Musik]
mit immobilien falsch ausgelegt
ok
und dann wünsche ich euch nur von hinten
in den raum so dass ich nicht gekommen
jetzt habt ihr fünf minuten lang zeit um
zu besprechen lasst eure erste idee sein
könnte oder wir kriegen das schmeckt
eigentlich auch schon das funktionsteam
geht aber ich habe den augen von den
anderen gesehen
die werden sich auf jeden fall zu
entscheiden ich glaube das hat mein
problem ich würde jetzt
im groben typ im zeitraum rapidler haben
wir gewonnen
nur minuten gar nicht unterhalten
wird nun zu guttenberg haben alles zur
nächsten
[Musik]
also nicht eigentlich eine bestimmte
richtung hatte man uns geht es ja gerade
gut
oder aber es gibt auch gute leistung
beträgt ja was ist das wenn du wenn wir
verlieren dann königs inhalt vielleicht
hat ihm zusammen auf
[Musik]
sie konnten nichts
also wir haben ja alles im juni musste
seine forderung
das hast du mein herz machen das nicht
kapierst du hast mich eigentlich eben
nicht gekriegt mit anfangs allerdings
versagt
[Musik]
wir dürfen wir es kommt gleich noch eine
extra regel ins spiel nach der ersten
runde wenn die sich auch besprochen
[Musik]
im ersten fall ist würde ich eigentlich
immer blauen also was sich
aber es wäre besser zu wollen
schnellstes andere trieben von dem
ganzen kreis sondern das gewand nehmen
können dh wer glaubt wir auf jeden fall
das risiko von komplettverlust bei den
gleichzeitigen gewinnt der andere teil
ist wenn man gewinnt da wir sowieso und
weniger das ist wirklich wenn ich mir
sicher dass hier andere vorleistungen
von schweinen erwarten
ja ich glaube dass die rot nehmen können
wir den das sowieso nichts im leben ist
es ist entweder die maut wurden beide
verlieren und können
die auch gelesen ja doch die sehen ja
wir sind schneller in deutschland aus
dem weg in das die ganzen land erlebt
habt nicht nicht aus böswilligkeit aber
einfach so weil das viel lustiges spiel
mit coolen ja das interessante strahlung
wird alles bisher machen allerdings ein
spannender
und dass die arbeiten nämlich nicht viel
gegen zusammen
ja ich würde glaube ich muss von neun
stunden nehmen obwohl einige blogger
haben möchte einfach nur nicht zu
[Musik]
sonderregel nach der ersten runde haben
dann beide teams die möglichkeit
bekommen eine person aus ihrem tier
auszuwählen und sie ins andere team zu
schicken sie mir zum beispiel bildet
beide bleiben und darauf wer sonst
irgendwie anders ist oder das eines
lebens hatten beide laufen noch die
mission wm alles gut nach hause
also was ist ihnen aus berlin deswegen
nicht
[Musik]
das geht aber nicht entschieden
also nehmen wir blogger nicht gesagt so
esslinger hochmodernes kameras und
ausgefallenen so ernst wäre okay dann
könnt ihr hier stehen bleiben die leute
rein
[Musik]
ich würde die teamcaptains in fünf
sekunden ihre karte zu zeigen
5 4 3 2 1
hättest du dich deutlich schlechter
gefühlt wenn du dasselbe ergebnis gehabt
hättest also null euro und das andere
team dafür das gesamte geld gehabt hätte
erschreckenderweise wahrscheinlich schon
weil dann mein plan ist aufgegangen wir
bzw
meine überlegung falsch gewesen als
hätte er gerade durch die anderen falsch
eingestellt hatte vielen dank dass ihr
das video bis hierhin angeschaut habt
wenn ich das gefallen hat lasst uns
gerne like oder ein kommentar dann
bewerbt euch über den link in der video
beschreibung bis zum nächsten mal
danke